the newest information on a Chinese spy
balloon shot down off the Atlantic coast
shows that U.S intelligence first
spotted it close to half a world away
our sources say the military tracked the
balloon for a full week before it
drifted across the continental U.S Ed
O'Keefe is at the White House Ed what's
going on
Nate good to see you you're right CBS
News has learned in U.S intelligence had
actually been tracking the balloon when
it took off from Hainan island off of
the South China Coast last month at that
point it then started drifting towards
Guam in Hawaii before making a northward
turn up to Alaska officials say it's
possible the balloon was blown off its
initial course by weather but they
insist the Chinese still had control of
it as it came south over the lower 48
states as for the three objects shut
down this weekend by these U.S fighter
jets the strongest Theory now from the
intelligence Community is that the
objects are benign we're just harmless
research balloons there's still no word
on the condition of the wreckage and in
the case of the object shot down over
Lake Huron we now know two missiles were
fired and the first missed but landed in
the water privately recorded cockpit
audio reveals that even the pilots were
perplexed by what they saw
definitely smaller than a car
now we've yet to hear from President
Biden about what he makes of all of this
why he decided to order the shootdown of
those two objects what he makes of China
using a spy balloon lawmakers briefed on
the details now say he should be saying
much more to explain this to the
American people but today Tony he's
instead giving a speech on the economy
up in Maryland
very interesting Ed thank you very much